your goal is to be a millionaire  and you start out making twenty thousand  a year  and then God gets you to 50.  but you mad cause you ain't a  millionaire well hold up man do you not  remember  that just a minute ago you wouldn't  didn't have a 20. so you got to show  gratitude for the 50. then somehow by  the grace of God you get to 150.  it's people making 150 who used to be  dead broke mad cause they not a  millionaire hold up partner do you  remember when you was just making the  50. now you didn't triple that and you  got to understand that there's joy in  the journey so if you don't show the  proper amount of gratitude you're never  gonna be happy you're never going to be  content and after a while man God gonna  get tired of you